since you're firing have you met with
former CIA director John Brennan yes
once I think and former National
Intelligence director Jim clapper yep
saw him the night before last I think
together no no actually I had dinner
with the two of them together and our
spouses you talk Trump case or no we did
all right after your hand-picked deputy
Andrew McCabe was fired you tweeted this
you said Special Agent McCabe stood tall
over the last eight months when small
people were trying to tear down an
institution we all depend on he served
with distinction for two decades I wish
Andy well I also wish continued strength
for the rest of the FBI on America needs
you you know the Inspector General found
that McCabe lied four times three of
them under oath Kimberley Strasse from
The Wall Street Journal tweeted a lot of
possible questions for you but here's
one please discuss Andrew McCabe and the
IG report that finds he lied repeatedly
both to you and about you do you still
believe he stood tall as you tweeted in
January or is he one of the small people
helping to tear down an institution yeah
I still believe he stood tall he
represented himself under and the
organization under tremendous stress
during that period after I was fired but
I read the IG report as you did it
concluded that Andy had not been candid
this is what accountability looks like
in the chesty prosecutor that's not for
me to say wait you said it in the
Clinton case well I was then the
director of the FBI which role that that
citizen should not be calling for the
prosecution of people in a case they're
not involved in but I do believe as it
routinely happens the IG will likely
refer it or has referred it to a US
Attorney's Office to look at it so did
you you see the disparity here where
people look at how the Clinton case was
handled and how the Trump case his
handle did did you tell what you don't
see disparity you tell lawmakers that
FBI agents didn't believe former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
was lying intentionally to investigators
no you didn't I saw that in the media I
don't know what maybe someone
misunderstood something I said I didn't
believe that and didn't say that about
the controversial test text messages we
just received a lot more up on Capitol
Hill today if you knew back then when
you were in charge of the investigation
and you saw those texts between Peter
struck and Lisa Paige the level of
animus they had against
President Trump what would you have done
I'd have removed both of them from any
contact with significant investigations
so shouldn't they're working including
those involving anybody connected to
president Trump but beyond that because
judge product then be questioned sure
it's a reasonable question action so
that they were dropping everybody
including pregnant candidate Trump so
Peter struck interviews Hillary Clinton
deals with the the bleach bit and the
server and Cheryl Mills all of that
interviews Michael Flynn and is integral
in this whole case but he's one of many
other people involved in all the things
you just ticked off it's a reasonable
question to ask and I can tell you this
when I saw that the text I was deeply
disappointed in them but I never saw any
bias any reflection of any kind of
animus towards anybody including me I'm
sure I'm bad mouthed in those texts I'm
just not gonna read them all never saw
it but that's why we have such a big
team of people you were in charge
banging on each other so the buck stops
with of course okay of course I'm
Jonathan tweeted in what was the
insurance policy deputy director McCabe
struck and Paige were discussing in his
office I have no idea any clue the
problem I had reading the text I'm sure
you've had the same challenges if
anybody pulled any of your listeners
text or viewers text and there's no
context it's hard to figure out what
they're talking about so I do a lot of
text there's a lot of context with those
guys well the ones I've looked at I've
had a hard time figuring out this
morning the president also said this on
Fox and Friends you look at the
corruption at the top of the FBI it's a
disgrace and our Justice Department
which I try and stay away from but at
some point I won't what do you think he
meant there I don't know I I hope he
didn't mean that he's going to decide by
executive Fiat to direct the actions of
what is supposed to be an impartial law
enforcement function Lady Justice has a
blindfold it should stay on did the
Inspector General interview you about
your handling of the memos sure yeah has
has has already and I expect a report
from them not on the handling of
classified information because that's
frivolous but on did I comply with
policy did I comply with my employment
agreement you said you didn't leave but
there's a New York Times tour in April
2017 that first reported the Lynch
you didn't write about it here in this
book cause you said it's classified the
New York Times wrote a lot about it did
the FBI public affairs coordinator story
not to my knowledge and I'm not gonna
comment on any stories collect I'm not
allowed to confirm or deny classified
information all right in the infamous
oval office meeting behind with
President Trump when you asked you to
say behind one on one you write in the
book that you felt awkward you didn't
like it correct you had been one-on-one
with President Obama in the Oval Office
correct but this was different yet
because he booted out the Attorney
General of the United States who was
lingering trying to stay as opposed to
the presidential photographer who
President Obama boots out sure okay so
you say you didn't push back when he
said he hoped you could see your way
clear of letting Flynn go that he was a
good guy hope you can let it go you said
you didn't push back and that he should
have known that he couldn't do that all
right so let's assume that's that's true
that he should have known that is it
possible there was another reason why
you didn't push back and that is that
you wanted to keep your job it's
possible but it's not the case at least
I don't remember thinking about that at
the time you told CNN last night that
you didn't think he'd be fired that you
know had you not been fired
you would still be working as FBI
director tonight yeah in fact that was
my intention to serve another six years
so despite the fact that now you say
that this president is morally unfit
that you say impeachment is too good of
a remedy you'll notice that I said in a
way I hope not because I think the
voters need to speak exactly and on the
media tour and the Blitz you basically
are encouraging voters to vote Trump out
of office because he doesn't line up
with your values I'm asking them to vote
their values and what I believe your
your viewers would agree our America's
values okay and but as of tonight had
you not been fired you'd still be
working for this guy that you say is
like a crime boss who is morally unfit
who you just don't agree with on
principle and values you'd still have
that job tonight absolutely be pretend
my goal would be to protect the FBI and
serve the President of the United States
you say I respect that office
tremendously you say the Republicans why
do you work with this president and then
sit there and say you would still have
this job tonight isn't
disconnect er no because elected
officials in Congress have a public
platform and are responsible for
communicating with the voters in a way
the FBI director is not my job would be
to protect the independence of the
institution their job should be to
represent the people who elected them
mr. Comey the book higher loyalty has
been very successful we appreciate your
time traffic and all sir thank you for
your patience and your good questions
thank you